all of which brings us to the question
of whether bitcoin and ether are
securities
remember bitcoin and ether are very
different now than initial coin
offerings
they exist they're transacted and
they're broadly used
in a recent speech given in june 2018 by
bill hinman the director of the division
of corporation finance at the sec
bill clearly articulated that it's the
sec's position that bitcoin and ether
are not securities that's a very
important conclusion and the interesting
question is what's the logical process
that leads to that conclusion
division director hinman reasoned as
follows
he said that to the best of his
understanding
bitcoin and ether
were sufficiently decentralized
that there was no one who played the
role of a promoter in the system
no one had sufficient control over the
system
not only was there no promoter there was
also no asymmetry of information
there was no situation where there was
someone like a promoter or like an
issuer who would know so much more than
people transacting the system that it
gave rise to the asymmetry that would
cause the registration requirement and
in registration the issuer of the
promoter has to disclose the additional
information they have so that purchasers
are adequately informed with regard to
the purchase and sale of the underlying
security
so we have a situation where the sec has
taken the position that sufficient
decentralization
means that there is no promoter
and when there is no promoter there's no
one who's available to file the
information you typically need in a
registration statement and that's not
troubling because there's no information
asymmetry
so purchasers of bitcoin or ether are
all sufficiently on an equal footing
that it's not like somebody knows
something that needs to be disclosed
that the other person doesn't know
now
it's an interesting process
but it's
susceptible to challenge for at least
three different reasons
first
let's understand that this is a speech
speeches do not have the force of law
whether they're speeches by presidents
or by division directors of the sec
decisions as to whether bitcoin and
ether are or are not securities
are as a practical matter going to be
made by the federal courts
if and when the appropriate litigation
actually arises
now
the logic in the speech may be
persuasive to the court or it may not be
persuasive but still it's just a speech
and that logic will probably have to be
articulated in a brief filed with the
court but it'll have no presidential
effect
again unless the sec takes formal
rule-making action
speeches and other pronouncements by the
sec do not have the force of law
second and perhaps most intriguing
division director hinman's analysis
depends upon
his understanding of the state of facts
regarding bitcoin and ether
as of june 2018.
what was his understanding of the state
of
facts we don't know
nothing in the speech has the division
director explain
what it is about bitcoin or ether that
leads him to the conclusion that it's
sufficiently decentralized
that's quite curious
because typically when the sec adopts a
rule or regulation
or when a court issues an opinion
there are findings of fact
the court will say i find the following
facts to be true and based on those
facts i apply the law and i reach the
following conclusion
when the sec adopts a rule or regulation
it will typically say we had hearings we
looked at a record these are the facts
that we find and because of these facts
we're going to adopt the following rule
well here we have the conclusion
that bitcoin is decentralized we have
the conclusion that ether is
decentralized we don't know the facts
upon which the division director is
relying
that that creates quite a mystery
because there are many people out there
that are going to want to build crypto
and argue that their crypto is not a
security and they're going to want to
argue that if bitcoin is decentralized
and if ether is decentralized we're also
decentralized
but if you don't have the foundational
facts supporting that conclusion how do
you make that argument
other problem with that approach
are the facts upon which the division
director is relying
all of the relevant facts or are they
even accurate
there's no evidence they took evidence
from people under oath
we don't know where those facts come
from
was it that they read a bunch of stuff
on the internet and believed everything
they read on the internet
was it something else
and do they know all the relevant facts
for example there's a site that you can
go to
that gives you the distribution of hash
power
on blockchain on the bitcoin blockchain
and
it turns out that if you have more than
50 percent of the hash power
you can do something called forking the
blockchain which changes the rules which
in effect gives you a tremendous amount
of control
well the data show that recently between
52 and 54 of the hash power
is controlled by
three different groups
of bitcoin miners
and all of these bitcoin miners are in
china
so
the ability to fork the blockchain
and to control the bitcoin blockchain
effectively exists in three different
entities all subject to the same
government's control
now
does that satisfy the definition of
decentralization
i don't know
did hinman know that those were the
facts
i don't know
we don't have any finding of facts which
makes us a very very difficult situation
for other people attempting to look at
this as precedent and comply with the
law
third area that's problematic
the actual articulation of the law
there's no precedent of which i'm aware
that looks at decentralization
as the primary factor in determining
whether an instrument is a security or
not
and i could actually take the hinman
speech and argue it doesn't go far
enough or argue that it goes far too far
the argument that it doesn't go far
enough is simple
many courts are taking a textualist
approach to the interpretation of the
law
if we look at the law from a texturalist
perspective and we look at the phrase
investment contract the word contract
jumps out at you
there's got to be a contract in order
for there to be an investment contract
the orange is not a contract
the orange is not a security
the combination of the management
contract with the land sales contract
that's a security
well if you look at bitcoin
there's no contract it's like the orange
if you look at ether there's no contract
it's like the orange
bitcoin and ether from that perspective
aren't securities because they're
sufficiently decentralized they're not
securities because they aren't
investment contracts because there
aren't any contracts
and by that logic if that's right and we
don't know that it is
then many other forms of crypto will be
able to argue we're not contracts either
and if we're not contracts we can't be
in investment contracts and therefore
we're not securities
so there's a path that we can follow
that argues that bitcoin and ether
aren't securities
for reasons that many other
forms of crypto can also use to argue
they're not securities
now i can also make an argument that
cuts in totally the opposite direction
and it says that hinman is entirely
wrong and that bitcoin and ether clearly
are securities
why
let's go back and let's take the
traditionalist approach
we have an investment of money
there is commonality
true there's no vertical commonality but
the courts say that vertical commonality
isn't necessary
true
every case of which i'm aware involves a
promoter or issuer
but that's only because the state of
technology that's existed until now
until the invention of the blockchain
you couldn't have anything that would
satisfy all of the howie elements unless
there was a promoter
but none of the cases say there must be
a promoter even though there always is a
promoter
it's like the story about the black swan
all right for a long time people
believed all swans were white why
because we'd only seen white swans
finally we go to we go to australia and
australia what do we discover black
swans
so the president we have to this point
is all dealing with white swans there
isn't a single case of which i'm aware
that says if there's no promoter then
you don't have commonality
so we have investment of money
arguably in a common enterprise
then expectation of profit look let's
face it bitcoin today is very very
rarely used for transactional purposes
bitcoin is most commonly bought and sold
on the expectation of profit
okay
and you've got the expectation of profit
primarily from the effort of others who
are the others
the miners
all right when you're buying bitcoin
you're sitting there passively and
you're hoping that the value of your
bitcoin is going to increase over time
and from that perspective
it's very different from the orange it's
very different from a block of gold
and it's different in the following
sense
when you have an orange and you expect
that that orange is going to increase in
value
you don't have to do anything
you just sit there and you wait for the
price of the orange to go up
in order for your bitcoin to increase in
value
the miners have to keep replicating that
blockchain
work has to be done
huge amounts of electricity have to be
consumed
people are spending tens of millions of
dollars designing asics chips in order
to be able to maintain this
infrastructure
it's not like a bar of gold that sits
there and its price goes up and down
it's not like an orange that sits there
and its price goes up and down
so
i can take the hinman speech
and i can say
what do we do with this first it's just
a speech
second it relies on a set of facts i
don't know what those facts are
and third it comes up with the new
articulation of law i can argue it's
terrific
and then i can argue well you know it's
good as far as it goes but it really
should go much farther and many more
things are not securities than hinman
says or i can go in the opposite
direction saying it misses the point all
together and bitcoin and ether they
really are securities because you don't
need to have a promoter and horizontal
commonality is sufficient
in other words
the confusion continues
and good faith efforts by the sec i
think to clarify a piece of the puzzle
have inadvertently made the puzzle a
little bit more complicated for us all